hello believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
in your journey today we're gonna learn
from best-selling author
Eckhart Tolle and my take on his top ten
rules for success vol 2 rule number 4 is
my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
also as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired by it as well and
if you leave it within the first couple
hours of this video going live you have
a chance to win one of two daily prizes
I need my story all the things that my
I've been telling myself in my mind
about myself and other people and my
parents and my relatives in my
co-workers and my ex-wife in my
ex-husband and what people did to me and
one but or what I did and shouldn't have
done failed to do Who am I without the
undeclared gov that I need to think
about this more so it becomes a habit
you'll place the abit your place of the
off the mental noise where you feel
that's me and so if every therapist
knows that you always reach a point with
their clients patients whatever
depending on the school of therapy
depends whatever you call the your
clients your patients they were there
comes a point when you hit that
resistance they don't want to be free of
their problems and that the big
challenge is there is this person going
to overcome that barrier because that
barrier is not just becoming free of my
problems but also becoming free of a
very limited and ultimately fictitious
sense of identity the me so that is what
I've described is the next step one
could say in the evolution of human
consciousness is stepping out of
self-talk which is the conditioned mind
and realizing there is much more to Who
I am
[Applause]
then this conditioned content of my mind
and that is the beginning of awakening
it's not it's not those words not not
that you need to believe that there is
much more to Who I am than the self talk
in my head because that is still self
talk in the head
I believe there's more to who I am and
you better believe it too analytical
thinking itself or processing
information is not creative
so to to even to find it create if a new
solution to a problem in your life
requires some creative insight so
whether it's a problem in your work
situation or your personal life or
something that you need to build or do
that you have come to a dead end or you
want to create something whatever it is
a work of art or a new system for the
computer I don't know the expressions
for that you need to go to the place
where creativity arises in every human
who brings who is creative has some
access to that even if they don't know
it it seems to me is a general pattern
at work that it is inherent in the
nature of physical existence of
life-forms that challenges our essential
ingredient of their lives and here and
part of the way through which they
evolve and when they say they evolve
their means is the one consciousness
evolves awakens
into this dimension through the
different life forms in different ways
and it awakens only because we are being
challenged and that's order that is a
quite
relieved to realize to be chance doesn't
mean is something wrong there's
something wrong with my life that
shouldn't be if you believe or act at
the as if this shouldn't be happening
then you get really unhappy then the
challenges become transformed into
unhappiness inside you yo if it's not
unhappiness its resentment if it's not
resentment it's its anger its self-pity
it's complaining its despondency itself
say for the simple reason that you're
misunderstanding the very purpose of
life and expecting something that your
mind has come up with so it different
some people are afraid of not succeeding
in whatever they do because they have a
self they they do their self image which
is derived from thinking what suffer if
I fail at something then I will my self
image will be injured and therefore I'm
not even going to try and again that's
to do with deriving your identity from
thinking and even the thought I have
failed is a lie I am a failure is an
even greater lie you have not failed you
can simply reinterpret I have learned
something here this is not from me for
example so but I believe the lies that
your mind produces so as you know people
many people live with a very hostile
mind that's but those people are the
motivation their motivation would
probably be very great I would hope to
get out of their minds but first I need
to realize that their problems are self
generated mind generated
may be surprised to know that there are
millions billions of people on the
planet who have that same thought
pattern there is something wrong with me
Rick it's part of the human ego but so
you bring in the awareness and that will
change everything that's the only true
key if you fail
next time you're the anger arises what
happens you will become aware
immediately after the anger has subsided
and then oh there it was and I wasn't
present and then the that the moment
will come when you are there in the
first if you can catch the anger the
first moment it comes or if you might
even see that it could be the result of
a thought that creates the anger and if
you can be there in the first moment
because before it becomes to fully-blown
anger then you can stay there it might
not even become fully blown anger if you
catch it the first moment you can feel
the first stories of anger you may only
have three seconds if you may come very
quickly and guess like an explosive
energy you may only have two three four
five seconds just to bring the stay
there with your awareness and feel it
although it's coming there it is that's
the pain body the angry pain body coming
and if you catch it in the early stage
don't suppress it I catch it I mean feel
it be there as a witness then you can
stay even as it grows the witness grows
with it it may not even draw it will
have to see whether it still grows into
full-blown anger or not that doesn't
matter and so you be thankful for your
anger because the anger can become a
very important spiritual practice for
you because through it awareness can
grow so it
it's a sometimes strange for people to
see it you can be thankful for things
that you think are the most difficult
obstacles in your life but they become
they can become your greatest
opportunity for spiritual awakening use
it as part of your practice there is a
source of power in you that transcends
the person and it's not egoic power over
somebody and it's one with the power
that is the power of life in the
universe where all life arises and
people sometimes have a problem with
self-confidence or valuing yourself and
sometimes you try to convince yourself
but changing your thinking that you are
actually good enough that you should be
self-confident but there is a better way
to find the source of self-confidence on
the egoic level self-confidence is there
because you see you can tell yourself
I'm actually more intelligent than most
of these people
or I'm better-looking than most I have
to remind myself that I'm better-looking
in most and then you okay I feel a bit
more confident now
or you say I've actually have more money
than these people so I should I have
more self-confidence whatever it is some
way of convincing yourself and then you
compare yourself with others and then
you focus in on those areas where use
fields superior to others and try not to
think about other areas where inevitably
you are inferior to others because he
cannot be superior in all areas it's a
complicated game when you start start
comparing yourself to other people and
if you want to bolster yourself
confidence and you only have to focus on
where you feel I'm actually better than
most but that doesn't really work that
well so there is a better way of self
confidence that has nothing to do with
comparing yourself with others or with
feeling you are better than or not as
good as and that is direct access to
inner power you don't need any
comparison you can have it right now at
this very moment if you're not stuck in
your thinking mind but take your
attention a little bit beyond the
thinking mind and then realize that you
are the presence behind the thinking
mind without which there could be no
thinking you're the aware presence
behind it all that is deeper you've gone
deeper than the thinking mind and that
aware presence is where power resides
and it's not yours because it connects
you with universal power therefore you
don't need to compare yourself to
anybody anymore or feel as the ego
always does that you are either superior
or inferior
to somebody else it's a not a
comfortable way to live where you have
to classify yourself and you meet people
and so you if the fear is over I might
be inferior or behind that fear is a
desire to be superior what happens when
you pay attention to the way in which
you interact with objects and what is
okay to use every minute of the day this
you pick something up you put something
down you unbutton your shirt you you
take off your shoes you lift this put
this there
open your bag zipper back Shh
you look ins inside take something out
can you feel it as you take it out can
you feel the texture of that and then
you put it on the table it makes it
sound as you put it on the table and
then you have a glass of water and the
light is reflected in it and it moves
perhaps you drink and it tastes and you
put it down again and then you look at a
familiar object and instead of using it
as always as a means to an end here you
have the luxury of occasionally just
taking an ordering object that you
handle every day and just for a few
seconds give it give it attention and
acknowledge its being just as that as
that object just feel it see it makes it
as it makes a noise as you put it down
and again you bring in sense perceptions
getting dressed in the morning putting
pants on they make a noise as you put
them all
a little bit investment do things you
pick up the toothpaste you hold it for
moment put the cap on that sink click
then turn on the tablet and then while
you brush your teeth you turn off the
tap because you don't want to waste
water but but that's not part of the
exercise it's natural for them and it's
you can actually begin to like and to
enjoy the tiniest things around you that
would normally be completely overlooked
the essence of the way in which you
interact with the world of objects and
that brings a richness into your life
that doesn't depend on how many objects
your own you don't need to own them to
interact with them and so here did you
acknowledge their beingness and you
sometimes you might just put your hand
as I'm doing now here's a table it's
wood and I'm putting my hand on it and
for a moment I feel the smooth texture
surface of this table and it it feels
very pleasant and I don't but I don't
need the mind to tell me that I can see
I can sense that and the strange thing
is even so-called
inanimate objects in a strange way have
a life of their own you know I'm
experiencing anger of course you
wouldn't say that I'm experiencing anger
but to say I am upset or I
SiC you know it's really sort of
embedding that into yourself where you
say you know I am having an upset well
if you have something can give it away
that's right so it's already progress if
from saying I am angry or I am upset you
say there is anger in me or there is
upset in me you have already separated
your essential identity from the
emotional state so you are no longer
reinforcing the emotional state through
your identification so that's a really
it's the beginning of inner
transformation it's that separation from
the passing mental or emotional state
the true self-esteem comes from not
identifying with form you know whether
we even want to call that surface team I
don't know the true sense of worthiness
and of power true power comes when you
realize the formless in yourself that
dimension and that all power comes from
that but it's not it goes far beyond the
person that you are and then you are
rooted in the formless so to speak or
you are eight and that this enormous
sense of worthiness in there but it's
not comparative it's not more than you
see the same worthiness in everyone even
if they don't know it for themselves yet
so there's power but not not more then
there's just there's just the power of
life itself and you know everybody is an
expression of that although they may not
know it yet everybody so this is your
transcend conventional self esteem and
it doesn't mean you lose your sense of
worth it shifts into something much
deeper if you think the world is full of
evil people you will meet many evil
people
and in other words unconscious people
and even people who are on the brain or
halfway between constant unconscious
when you come together with them your
belief will pull them into
unconsciousness and that's karma so
gamma is the complete absence of
conscious presence and so it's it's
automatic it plays itself out and time
does not free you of karma that is a
misperception that if you only have
enough time eventually you can become
free of karma karma reduce itself and
repeats itself but this is it's a wheel
and so the only thing that can free you
of karma is the arising of presence and
why how is it that for us some person
presence right I don't I cannot tell you
why I only know that at any point in the
wheel of karma presence can come in it
can happen to this it can happen to a
criminal in prison condemned to death it
can happen to somebody who's never heard
of anything spiritual it can happen to
someone who has been meditating for
thirty years or not happened to some
same person has been meditating for
thirty years so in your own life I can
see from what you're saying that
presence has already I can sense that
presence has already come into your life
and presence frees you from karma not
all at once
karma has an enormous momentum meaning
the patterns in yourself the thought
patterns the emotional patterns the
reactive patterns there's enormous
momentum behind that but as presence
arises gradually kama diminishes in its
the energy behind it diminishes and
gradually you experience a fading
of those patterns they become weaker
you're no longer completely in the grip
of those patterns so as presents arises
there's a gradual fading out of common
not that it matters that much anymore
because once you are present you can as
we the previous questioner said when we
were talking about some thoughts still
arising certain negative source that's
still part of the Karma the old patterns
the unconscious habit patterns inherited
they still arise but it's no longer
problematic and they no longer cause the
suffering that they would have caused
before because they are seen in the
light of awareness so the light of
awareness arises and in the light of
awareness the patterns no longer
dominate your life they no longer run
your life and if occasionally it happens
that the patterns do take over then
after a little while you present certain
CR well there it was again pain body is
part of karma you which may be strong in
some people not so strong in others and
so as presence arises you are freed from
karma it has and then you have another
completely different factor coming into
your life and so for example for a
person to become free of collective
karma you need a considerable amount of
presence for that to come in to remove
and it then will remove you in one way
or another either internally you find
yourself completely free you might still
live in a violent society but internally
you would be free there is such a is a
possibility you can have a holy man or
woman living surrounded by violence it's
possible it's rare but possible or very
often it happens that life removes you
out of there and you find yourself
somewhere else so let's say vast
collective karma for example in the case
of let's say we think of the Taliban
there you have all kinds of unconscious
movements you had Soviet Communism
you had National Socialism in Germany
and for firstly being born into that and
not being drawn into that
unconsciousness requires considerable
presence so not that many people for
example in Germany at when Hitler came
to power not many people were able to
remove themselves somewhere some artists
some writers they they left they could
see what was happening and they they
they were strong enough not to be
identified with a collective when there
had been a tradition of obedience to
Authority for hundreds of years a
tradition of following your lead and so
on to to take yourself out of that
collective karma requires considerable
presence but some people had it so it is
our destiny then to go beyond karma by
being the receptacles for presence all
you can do to be helpful in this world
and help others is those people that you
come into contact with you may for
everybody in this who is awakening will
find that sooner or later that they
become a kind of teacher to others and
what a spiritual teacher does to teach
points are the possibility of awakening
out of identification with unconscious
patterns which means the spiritual
teacher teaches you to go beyond Karma
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because live now oh six
asked me to if there's someone you like
me to profile in their future top ten
please check out the link down in the
description below and you can cast your
vote on who we should do next I also
want to give a quick shout out to Lynn
Poe dedi from outsourcing angel thank
you so much Lynn for picking up a cup of
my book your one word and going through
it and finding your one word of love and
then sharing it with your newsletter as
well I really really really appreciate
the support and I'm so glad that you're
applying the wisdom from it thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
to meditate successfully the idea that
you're doing a meditation can be quite
an obstacle so maybe that's the first
thing we can get rid of tonight the
preconceptions and the expectations that
come with it so why did we call it
guided meditation well we had to use
some word to get you here
[Music]
[Music]
meditation is usually something that you
do among many other things doing implies
all kinds of things implies time even
future to some extent
and yet through meditation if you even
want to call it that and it's better not
to call it anything it's not to do with
doing it's not a doing it's the
realization that you are of being which
underlies all doing is prior to all
doing thoughts emotions is prior to that
the simple realization not the
realization who you are because there
can be so many perspectives on that not
the realization how you fit into the
totality of the cosmos how that
seemingly a little life fleeting
existence fits into the totality
somewhere not realizing how I fit into
the whole it is impossible to comprehend
but an alignment with the totality
without the need to mentally understand
anything realization the simple
realization that you are which is
expressed in the sublime words I am
and if you've missed elementary grammar
at school you might not realize that I
am is the first person singular of the
verb to be
you think it's two completely different
words
[Music]
the realization that you are not a Sun
concept but as a deeper sensing of the
life that you are the aliveness alive
and something helpful to realize that is
to pretend for one moment that there is
no past in no future
I'm saying pretend so that everybody is
still with me if I say it
if I say it there is no past and future
some of you might suddenly start
thinking just a second
aren't you going to sign books in an
hour
[Music]
the moment you go into thinking you're
off into the realm of mind the realm of
things object objects in consciousness
every thought is an object in
consciousness and every sort has a
pulling power
that's right arise this and it pulls
your attention in and you start thinking
okay but today's I mean I came here half
an hour ago there must be a past not
realizing of course when you came here
it lost the present moment and when the
books are going to be signed it'll be
the present moment because it there is
nothing else okay button to don't no
need to believe that let's pretend
[Music]
let's pretend for a moment that there is
no past in future okay well let's just
say past in future become a referral
yeah oh you are there's only this
it is the entry point into a realization
I am